Speaker 1: Kerry Lake now participating in a
prayer circle to try to pray away the stolen
election. You know, there used to be a time
where these religious conservatives would try
to get people to pray away the gay. They would
say, if you pray enough and if I pray enough,
maybe you won't be gay no more. If you remember
that viral clip. They have moved on, I guess,
from trying to pray for people not to be gay or
for themselves not to be gay. I don't even know
to praying for the winner of an election
to lose. That's fundamentally what they
they're praying for here. And you will
see Carrie Lake in this video. If you
were white, if you were watching
with her head bowed in prayer.
Um, Christ, this country is really messed up.
Speaker 3: We cannot be part of thievery. And,
Lord, that which the people
have done to try to steal this
election shall come back upon their own
heads. For now is the season and the hour
for things to begin to shift and change
as global freedom shall cover this earth.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so I would not bet on that one
working necessarily. I don't know that I would put
too many eggs in that basket, for lack of a better
term. And Kerry Lake continues to invoke God.
Here is another segment. And this is very much
like, you know, when when an athlete says, well,
I have to thank God for this victory. And it's
sort of like. God is now choosing like who wins
a tennis match. That's what's going on. Or that
like a curling thing or a soccer game. It's God.
And why is God making the choices in this way?
Did the other team not pray enough? Did they not
pray correctly? It's all very weird. But Kerry,
like applying that here to her election, I guess.
Speaker 4: People can, for starters, pray. We
really need God in this world. We need God in
our hearts, in our homes and in our country.
Speaker 1: She quite literally doesn't have a
prayer of being the next governor of Arizona.
Speaker 4: And I know God's making a big
comeback in this country. I feel
it. I talk to people who say,
I started to return to church. I brought God back
into our family's lives. So important right now,
we're due for a couple of miracles. I think.
Speaker 1: It's just such a fantasy
world that these people live.
Speaker 4: In. But I also believe
we have on top of that, we have a really good
court case and we're going to open people's eyes
to what went wrong. Yeah, you know, there's times
I felt just like the voters out there in Arizona
despondent over the last couple of weeks. Right.
Because we have such a we have such an amazing
movement. And then I think about what God, you
know, our father is doing. He's. Imagine if you
if your dad said to you, I have such great hope
for you and I believe in you so much that I'm
going to put you in charge of something difficult.
Speaker 1: This is just so crazy. Listen, what if
God wanted her to win? Why didn't
she just win? Right? Like, is.
God is all knowing and all powerful and involved
in every absolutely every decision. Sports
decisions. And you know who wins the lottery and
who wins elections? God is involved everywhere.
And yet God allowed Katie Hobbs to seemingly get
more votes and to have the election certified and
imminently to be inaugurated as the governor
of Arizona. And then now you have to pray
for God to change his mind. Did you not pray
enough before or did you pray the wrong way,
or did Katie Hobbs have better prayer or more
pray it? It's just insane. And it's the same
type of grift that would get people to even donate
to somebody like Carrie, like in the first place.
We'll have all these Carrie late clips if you can
stomach them on our Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show. And of course, they will all
be on the YouTube channel at YouTube.com slash The
David Pakman Show. Make sure you're subscribed.
It is free. And we will be back right after this.